all right so we're wrapping up 2017 I've
told you 2017 has been a tough year for
the show in a few ways we had YouTube's
D monetization ad pocalypse where we
lost a lot of our YouTube revenue we had
our Amazon affiliate link shut down
completely and totally where we lost
100% of our revenue including the
revenue earned while that link was still
active in the previous month or two they
just shut the entire thing down but one
of the I guess I'd call it sort of
literally like a saving grace has been
the steam at platform st double e MIT
dot-com which is sort of like a curated
reddit of sorts where we have started
uploading our content you can find me
there at steam accom slash at david
pakman show and if you go there you'll
notice that a lot of our content is
listed there in the same way that it
shows up on YouTube or on reddit or
other platforms but next to the green up
votes that you see you see a dollar
amount and that's because the way Steam
it works is that by upvoting our content
you support it financially and it's not
necessary to get into the sort of
technical underpinnings of this of which
I only have a loose grasp but needless
to say it's a blockchain based platform
with its own currency called the steam
back dollar and something called steam
power and this really has been towards
the end of the year a great thing for
recreating some of the lost revenue so
what you can do is go to steam it calm
that's st double e MIT hit the join
button very very simple and easy to do
it will take a couple of days to get
your account approved but once that
happens it's just so simple that it
almost sounds like it couldn't possibly
be a real thing but it is follow us we
are steam it com
slash @ sign david pakman upvote and
comment on the stuff that we upload and
participate in the community because
there is a lot of really good stuff on
the community and not only will you be
supporting us financially by doing this
you actually will earn financial rewards
yourself and I've had people get in
touch and say David I join
this thing just to support you and I
really like the other content that's on
there but I'm coming away with this with
a few dollars here and there for myself
merely by curating because the way that
it works is every piece of content
that's put up a majority of the
financial rewards associated with that
piece of content go to the Creator
meaning me if I put up a david pakman
show video but some portion of the
rewards for each piece of content
anywhere between 10 and I believe as
high as 20 or so percent are actually
set aside for the curators meaning the
people who find an upvote and comment on
that content so it's a really great
platform we've put a link in the
description to this video which you can
click on create an account follow us
participate in the community and we'll
be doing a lot of interactive segments
with the steamin community as well